uh good afternoon everybody thank you
for coming along to this hearing for the
code of practice for subdivision land
use and development a joint uh hearing
between Southland District Council and
invercargill city council I'm Michael
Morris I am the manager of governance
and legal and it is a pleasure to
welcome you all here today for this
hearing uh first things first uh before
we get started is the safety procedures
uh please do not walk in the middle of
the circle it is full of trip hazards
and we would ask you to please stay
outside the disc Circle uh obviously in
the event of an evacuation we had our
trial yesterday so we know it works uh
staff will escort you out of the
building and we assemble over by the
wall of H J's uh Smith so that way
toilets who have walked past uh male
toilets at first and then female toilets
are a bit further along the corridor
both on the lift
so with that and an event of earthquake
I think we all know what to do and so
I'm not going to go into those details
so first of all of a business is this is
the first time the Joint Committee has
met is to call for nominations from the
committee to be a chair so I now invite
any nominations uh
to be made
I'd like to nominate you in that note
please do we have a second before that
thank you all those in favor
thank you that has passed unanimously uh
congratulations councilor Ludlow and
I'll hand over to you thank you good
thing nobody else wanted it
thank you welcome along
um this is actually quite a unique event
and I congratulate staff from both
councils and working together for a
combined code of practice
um and it's an approach that I think
certainly the professionals working in
the sector will welcome
um we're all present so there are no
apologies so Rhiannon could I ask you to
introduce the report and also the staff
that are attending please
thank you chair um
I'm Rhiannon Suter I'm the strategy and
policy manager here at ICC along with
Teresa cabinet at Southern District
Council we've been coordinating this
process so I'll briefly introduce
the report
um as the chair has said this has been a
process that officers have been working
on for quite a while with the goal of
providing a more coordinated response
across the region both to support the
developer community and to enable a more
responsive code that can be updated more
frequently to reflect changes to best
practice around such issues as climate
change kilmari and how we deal with
water for example
so this report is presented on that
basis it speaks to the recommendations
that could be made from this committee
to the two separate councils to revoke
the existing bylaws on the basis as the
previous reports and consultation
materials have outlined that this code
of practice is recommended as a more
responsive structure and following the
consultation it also speaks to the
matters that have been raised by the
submitters some of which are here to
today to speak to their submissions the
technical teams at both councils have
met and gone through all the submissions
and these are the form the basis of the
recommendation that's sitting in the
report in front of you it is recommended
that when we have a new joint code of
practice that it be in place for one
year before review this is to reflect
the fact that this is a unique process
in the two councils working together
there will no doubt be some items which
will need to be updated to reflect and
practice and it also will give more time
for engagement and partnership with
terramarama to improve the elements
relating to tell Maru within the process
one last thing around the process that I
will mention is that this hearing today
is regarding the code of practice
element it is not regarding the elements
for the RMA District plan changes which
will be handled separately by each
Council following the decision of this
hearing panel today
so
on that basis I'll just introduce
officers on the ICC side um Grant here
has been coordinating from the technical
perspective and so he will coordinate
the kind of answering of any questions
and the um explanation of
recommendations
um Hannah to my left has been
coordinating for writing the report from
the ICC side and pulling together the
structure of the report so shares across
all the detail
um I'll now pass to you Theresa to add
anything else you want to add on the
basis of the report and to introduce the
colleagues from Southern District
Council
District Council
I've got nothing further to add thank
you but staff here we've got Nick Lewis
from our rodent team we've got Brian
Ward from our water and waste team and
Mark day from our community facilities
thank you thank you any of the earrings
panel have any questions at this stage
so my intention is to
um
move the first four recommendations
which is to receive the report
uh to receive the written submissions
which is item four uh agree to receive
one late submission and hear from that's
kind of order
and note the submitters that are to be
heard and then we'll get into hearing
those who wish to speak any questions
about that
wonderful uh well I'll move from the
chair then the first four
recommendations if this is secondary
a second thanks Paul questions comments
put the motion all in favor against
carried so that uh brings us through to
the first of our submitters which is
Lloyd Gauntlet on behalf of absolute
land this stage I should point out that
absolute land do hold offices
immediately next door to my day job but
Lloyd and I haven't had any
conversations about this anyway Lloyd
please take a seat welcome along
thank you
um yeah thank you for the opportunity
just to present today
um I am going to walk through uh some
six different uh areas of my submission
um the first being
5.3.17.3 uh and this is regarding the
engineering uh design
uh required for all right-of-ways all
private right-of-ways
um so if I can just quote the proposed
wording in the code of practice
private pavement shall be designed as
for public roads and residential rural
payments shall have minimum formation
thickness in accordance with ostros
guidelines and then they shall be
designed in 30 years
um it I would question whether they uh
this is appropriate for up to three
um dwellings coming off a single right
away
um the reason being
that they're often the right away is
often constructed
prior to dwellings
um and this is following so the
dwellings will come after two to four is
issued
um and those right-of-ways will see
heavy traffic for construction that sort
of thing and
they and then a place as a onus on those
right-of-ways that's over and above what
we would expect for
um for smaller right-of-ways
um this the second uh issue they come to
a 6.2.8
which is regarding the calculation of uh
climate change
so uh the the proposed
code of practice
um references uh some factors that
designers are to be aware of and
uh once again quoting from the rainfall
design charts shall be adjusted to take
into account the the predicted increase
in rainfall intensities
from the effects of climate change to do
this the designer shall use the
following factors a temperature increase
of 1.5 degrees a design Horizon to 2050
an RCP of six in the design event
duration of six hours
um this is fundamentally not correct
when uh designing
for climate change adjustment
so if I can hone it on RCP six
this is a representative concentration
pathway provided by niwa
and this is not subject to a direct 1.5
degree change this is actually a model
based on uh further
further models provided to niwa from the
intergovernment panel on climate change
so to to request a 1.5 degree
calculation on top of rcp-6 is
actually is not a correct way of
interpreting that information provided
furthermore
their design Horizon is is very short
and the event durations of six hours are
very long in a lot of cases and will end
up in undesigned under designing
stormwater
mitigation that is
um
and then
uh so the next point is 7.4 a which is
uh Wastewater disposal within 10 years
so from the code from the proposed code
no pipe system is immediately available
or will not be available within 10 years
of the subdivision application
um so this is uh essentially stating
that
we cannot install uh the developer
cannot install on-site Disposal Systems
um if it's if there's an intent that uh
the infrastructure will be provided
within 10 years
um
uh I would challenge that this is not a
set or miserable condition because
although they may be in the ltp
there's no guarantee that within 10
years that infrastructure will be built
um
and so if we have a site that under the
the district plan or the rest of the
code is is capable of disposing
Wastewater to site this is effectively
declining what is a viable development
um furthermore that development may be
uh it may be connected at a later date
if we if it is
um
given the go ahead to to have on-site
disposal at this point in time
um and so that is the same Reflections
on 8.3.5.12
which is regarding the water connections
uh the same wording is present no no
connect no development within 10 years
if there is
uh proposed infrastructure
um brings me to our 3A which is in the
standard drawings
um the M4 mine and local Road minimum
legal width is 20 meters
this in fact isn't quite aligned well it
is aligned currently with table 5.4 but
I note that on other submissions there
was a deviation from the 20 meter uh
blanket within a minor local Road
um this
there's no infrastructure reason that I
can see that we would uh extend them to
20 meters there's enough Corridor what's
in there
um they're under the 4404
um
the the tables within there for Suburban
zoning brings those right down based uh
brings the legal Worth right down based
on
uh different uh dwelling units within uh
though serviced by those roads
um and so I think it's it's in uh the
city's best interest that
those are reduced in order to densify
development
um because I would I I see densifying
development as a
as a an objective that that we would
want to see from an infrastructure
perspective
um there's there's a that's also
supported by
um
the New Zealand Urban Design protocol
which I believe
um that ICC in particular has adopted
um in part at least
the uh brings me to
r3a once again where there's a statement
about six by six meter entrance way so
an entrance way
[Music]
um
uh adjoining a collector or a higher use
Road uh shall have six meter Carriage
Way for six meters entering
um this to this promotes some safety
concerns that I have
and I'll refer to design principles of
off-roads and also further advice
documentation from nzta on those two
principles one of them being driver
workload
and the other being perceived priority
uh if we consider driver workload
um if it's too high the advice is that
this leads to compensation By ignoring
relevant information this is from the
driver's perspective
so if we consider the scenario where
we're in high traffic the driver wishes
to turn into this right-of-way
um we have pedestrians and cyclists
coming from the same direction
um the vehicle believing they have
spaced into if there's a vehicle sitting
coming out of that right-of-way has
pressure to do so based on traffic
behind them
and and then
if we add into that the perceived
priority
um
this this is based on the the conflict
between Road users if priority is not
clear and so once leaving the live Lane
we would expect that the priority is
actually with the pedestrians and
cyclists
um this is further enforced by
delineation I.E Cuban Channel
uh the driver under high workload May
believe that they now attain priority
which heightens their response to leave
the live Lane and cross in front of uh
cyclists or pedestrians
I believe this creates a more
significant conflict than the head they
stayed in the live Lane
my final point is uh standard drawings
are 13 through 2r16 regarding the sump
pipe work
currently the pipe work that comes out
of the rear of the sump to an inspection
point and then makes its way back
through under the curb into the roadside
in most cases to the carriageway
this isn't desirable for a number of
reasons uh it's just more maintenance
it's harder to maintain you can't
actually have direct access to each
Junction
uh it takes up room in the booms
it will affect the Hydraulics of of that
system
um
and it's it's not easy to Define where
the pipe runs go because they're no
longer in straight lines so there are
examples of this uh in 444 building code
other territorial authorities present
this in their code of practices that you
can make direct runs from
those sumps with trapping hydrocarbons
just by using a y and that alignment
that's that's all I wish to speak to
thank you thanks Lloyd questions
can I just ask when you were talking
about intensification of density in the
urban area that is of course dependent
on infrastructural capacity
you'd accept that correct thanks and
when you were talking about the
right-of-way requirements was there any
consultation you've done with traffic
management Engineers around that or are
you doing that within your own skill set
no this was on my own skill set
thanks Lloyd any further questions
if not sorry Paul
um so you would have seen the responses
from staff to your submissions yeah have
you are you satisfied with
those outcomes or
um so the items that I've spoken to now
are ones I'm not satisfied okay
thank you thank you
now further questions
thanks Lloyd appreciate the submission
and for making time available this
afternoon thank you
Alby
welcome along
um
I'm civil engineer based at wsp here in
invercargill wsp is the Premier design
and engineering
consultancy of aotearoa we've been in
New Zealand for 150 years and currently
have 2 000 staff and 36 offices
and general Derby's piece of Courts the
code of practice we acknowledge this
code of practice is a better quality
than the previous two bottles
and appreciate the effort that's gone
into
from both ICC and UCC
we submitted 56 individual comments and
note that 38 have been accepted as us
um let me comment some of the ones that
weren't accepted
um
one of the one of the comments here on
Section 5.4.12 it was accepted in
relating to tactile surface ground
indicators so the yellow
pavers that um people that have low
vision rely on
um it was accepted they were going to
refer to the standards within the code
of practice
um I don't think it goes far enough I
raised this in 2016 and since then
there's been lots of examples around
invercargill in particular where they've
been installed incorrectly
so when they're installed incorrectly
they're a danger to people that are
blind
um I think you need to have more detail
on there so people can
know that they can do it correctly
rather than just referencing a standard
I think we need to have a bit more
information to upskill Industry and
Council staff as well on the right way
to do it um
the next section climate change as
mentioned by Lloyd's the section as it
stands as a contradiction
can't remain as is
um I can't you can't wait 12 months and
lots of other people have noted it needs
to change I'm happy to answer more
questions afterwards but it needs
effects it doesn't make sense
um that's the one thing you change is
that I'd be happy
um
the next one is relating to manholes
some exciting stuff
um of referenced the CCPA guidelines for
flight penetrations
um
this relates to the angle that pipes
come into manholes and where the joins
are between the manholes themselves and
pipes
um I've noticed across the industry
contractors get this wrong they order
the wrong manholes and they make them
the holes are in the wrong place it
means that the manholes aren't installed
properly and basically the
manufacturer's guarantees don't don't
fly and you probably won't get your
design life that you need so I think you
need to add them in there so they're
installed properly
um 7.3.8.4.4
is the internal fall through sewer
manholes and that old ICC kind of
practice there was a nicely table that
had
the falls through the saw man holes
based on the the angle of the pipes and
obviously the sharp of the angle you
need a bit more full for the sewage to
get around other than washing your
blockages
um it's been removed I think that table
needs to go back in pretty easy
can't post on that one
um
8.3.10.1 seismic design
the ICC water mains they have the
electorals the property connections they
come off at 90 degrees perpendicular to
the main
and what that means is in an earthquake
and what happened in Christchurch is
that the pipe can move separate to the
laterals and all those laterals could
those connections pop off and you have
basically leaks under the ground and a
whole lot of property connections and
they spend a lot of time in Christchurch
digging them back up and reconnecting
them so we're suggesting if you connect
them parallel with the main and sweep
them around you add at least essentially
slack into the main which means that
will resilient an earthquake price
actually doing it tomorrow we're doing
it it means that any new water mains if
they follow that standard you won't be
running around trying to dig them up
after an earthquake to get water back to
people
Landscaping
um there's a reduction
in the response to two years it was five
years we were happy with five years
just wanted to point out a bit of a
contradiction
um at the start of the Landscaping it
talks about how our opportunities for
landscaping are diverse ranging from
specimen tree planting to planting with
Associated existing indigenous
vegetation traffic management devices
riparian margins Wetlands swales rain
Gardens ponds Reserve reserves and
specific landscape features and
development
that's great we're all for that but then
later on it states that if there's any
Landscaping proposed that is
more than minimum that Council want to
approve the cost so it seems like you're
trying to have it both ways you want the
developer it's got lots of landscaping
and a good stormwater treatment and you
know move at the Times which is great
but then you don't want to pay for
maintenance so five years of maintenance
on the developer I think is suitable
after five years the maintenance cost by
the council should be low enough that
should be picked up by The Irregular
maintenance
assistant as an example with the indoor
roundabout and the Elvis Road roundabout
we put thousands of plants in and it is
a new thing for people to try and get
used to the maintenance of them but they
do provide a benefit called stormwater
treatment and for
just having load of plants
and the final point I want to make
um there's other few other submitters
have commented on redefining the term
jio professional
um term is comes from 444 which is the
overall standard
um and it's actually quite clear what um
what it encompasses
and by lowering that standard you take
on risk of unqualified or underqualified
practitioners supervising and certifying
Works potentially they may not be
qualified to do well they shouldn't be
don't
so we
recommend that you stay with the term
Geo professional
so thanks shall we thank you
questions oh sorry yep
can't get out of The Graham Norton just
here
um your comments around climate change
what are the standards that you're
suggesting would be better than those
that
we've put forward not really a change it
was some of the standards contradict one
another as Lloyd said RCP sex is fine we
accept that but that contradicts the 1.5
degrees climate change rise because it
could be more it could be less the RCP
six
see it's dead standard
um then what in our submission I think a
few others we commented on what we
suggested which is just RCP six using
herds which is the newer
they have a website so anywhere in
Southland you type in the address it
gives you the rainfall parameters for
rcp-6 which is that climate change
parameter and then use that in your
design
um
based on the relevant
time of concentration
which is the catchment size if you've
got a big catchment you have a larger
kind of concentration some more
catchment your little one so the six
hours
doesn't make sense either because
catchments are different sizes they need
at time of concentration relative to the
size of your catchment
thanks Emily other questions
um well just on that subject is not
actually in your what you're saying this
morning but I noticed the difference in
Cobra pipe sizes between the um
3.75 and
what we're got in here at three
um 100 so 375 300. do you have a comment
on that given climate change I
but I think it's less to do with climate
change and more the fact of maintenance
if you put a bigger pipe in
you can often walk away for it for
longer a lot of our culverts don't get
cleaned out as often as they should so
it can be a way of
minimizing the maintenance long term
because that 375 might
half full of sediment but it still
operates and it still has capacity
um ncta on all of the sun plates have a
300 mil requirement and it's not because
of capacity it's because of Maintenance
you can walk away for
a long time and know that they'll still
function and they won't lock
so it's a practical point you have to
put a bigger pipe in you don't need to
deal with the maintenance
thanks any further questions
if not thanks Shelby appreciate your
submission and your time this afternoon
uh if we can get Josh and I think Josh
is coming advisor
sorry Josh I've got my back to you my
apologies welcome along
got it um so I'm Josh Neville I'm the
South Island development planning team
leader for crying Aura
um and sort of we look after the policy
and Regulatory planning side of the
organization
um so a brief bit of background just in
case no one's aware client order is a
crown entity um formed in 2019 and it
brung together uh housing New Zealand uh
hlc and kiwibuild as well as a couple of
others we've got two primary roles one
being a public landlord and the other
one partnering with the development
Community Murray local and central
government on Urban Development outcomes
so in invercargill Southland we've got a
little over 300 homes
and planning intentions for 21 to
fy24 we've got about 50 homes either in
purchase construction or planning
um just a high level from our
submissions probably more high level
than some of the technical experts that
you're hearing from so we sh we largely
support the shift from bylaws to a code
of practice and we're pleased to see it
as joint response
um as much as possible we like to see
the matters dressed outside of the
district plan where it's able to be
addressed outside of the district plan
and that just avoids so schedule one
processes where further changes are
needed
um from our submission I'll just uh
cover off the key topics
um largely we accept the staff response
there and the metas um raised by other
submitters there's a few that we relying
quite well on
um so we are
we were surprised I think when we were
reviewing it not seeing
um Maori design
statements and uh embedded throughout
and sort of Murray design principles
being taken into account with some of
the design so understanding that staff
response has come back and said that
that's up for review
um with the one year review and that's
further incorporation of those are
likely uh following some work with tiara
marama so we're happy to see that and
would be pleased to see monofino and
teal Mari design principles be added
through the likes of designer checklists
noting that this is pretty standard and
most of the codes and practices around
New Zealand
um we also want to see a few amendments
to the voting design and I know it
hasn't been accepted this one but we
would like to see a a low speed uh or a
smaller cross-section Road
largely the focus for that is around
um
Redevelopment and intensification areas
where you're seeing Urban and Brownfield
areas get redeveloped over time
um and more likely this is sort of in
line with the typical size of a
right-of-way or a job
um but being a public road it enables
the likes of free public access to and
through sites
finally measures to improve just the
storm water
flooding responses sort of climate
change there and in light of sort of
recent events
um I think reading through the code of
practice we we would just concerned that
it hadn't gone far enough to address the
potential future impacts of climate
change
and I see that that's covered quite
extensively too by other submitters so
that's probably something that will get
reviewed into the future but yeah
definitely just a some further work on
that would be something that would
support
aside from those matters and the other
matters raised in our submission were
largely supportive of the code of
practice though and I will stop there
thank you
thanks Josh
questions counselors
Justin around recommended Spades
isn't that actually part of another
process that Council goes through Josh
oh the speed limits yes setting that
um I think in the cross section for the
voting design we we were sort of
suggesting that a low speed environment
cross-section uh be added and there
would be for a smaller Road width
um
enabling
uh the likes of if you were redeveloping
a Brownfield site or an agglomeration of
residential Parcels you could introduce
a smaller Road through Road through the
site that could become a public road at
the moment seeing in the code of
practice there isn't much scope for that
to become a public road least commenting
on the actual setting of the speed limit
through there that the design standard
for something like a below 30ks an hour
speed limit Road that's what we're
intended for our and our submission
point there thanks for the clarification
shots more design process rather than
the formal limit
and just uh Josh under 0.6 of your
submission
um I see you're saying both the matter
is supported and the changes requested
are to basically ensure that
Ora can carry out a state or statutory
obligations and fulfill its development
Urban Development functions so do you
think there's impediments to that now
that this proposal eliminate or
is there a way to go or what
uh largely this is an improvement
um particularly when I'm looking at our
development aspirations
um so this will assist in that process
um the in particular the routing design
one I I'm thinking about a particular uh
development that we're looking at
um that is still going through the
process
um
aside from that that that's more a
I don't perceive this having significant
impediments to our
development aspirations the other things
such as District plan processes and
enablement of density and things
uh
do create impediments to achieving some
of the outcomes that we're seeking
thank you
any further questions
if not thank you Josh appreciates your
time and for reporting the submission on
behalf of Kanga order
thank you very much
Don
welcome along
foreign
minor technical stuff that I've included
in my submission that um
there's just a few of the points that
I've raised here that I want to speak to
um
I guess the first one three two four six
yeah it would be good if um we've
we've had a slightly different policy
in the past between the two councils in
respect of council taking over and
maintaining services on private land
as a general rule the district council
have been happy to take sewers and water
mains
um over and maintain them despite the
fact that they were located on private
land with you know within a subdivision
you usually within a ride away whereas
I'll stand to be corrected but I don't
think the City generally it hasn't
encouraged that and in fact it's it's
refused to
it would be nice to see some
clarification of that I think those
Services should be taken over by Council
where they're accessible
um not suggesting Council takes over
private grains are serving one or two
houses where they're down the back of
the house or anything like that but we
were serving multiple Lots offer right
away
the service is located within the right
away so they're readily accessible for
Council staff to come and maintain them
they're given accounts was given an
easement
so that it's got that right then I think
those rate payers deserve the same level
of service as their counterparts who
live on the street
um
the connection of power and telephone
services
generally speaking so that's three two
four seven here looking back
Southland District Council had a pretty
rigorous policy of an existing on Power
and Telephone Connections at the time
subdivision
invercargill City haven't and
the world hasn't stopped turning just
because the invercargill city didn't
require power and Telephone Connections
and it may seem like an insignificant
issue I can assure it's not it's a major
issue when people are doing Enfield
subdivision
I'm not talking here about Greenfield
subdivision that goes without saying if
you do a Greenfield subdivision at
multiple Lots
I can tell you now you won't sell the
allotments without paying telephone to
the boundary but on infield subdivision
in the urban areas
it's a non-necessary experience at the
time that you're developing
it's been a cash cow for chorus we've
had a stupid situation in the Southland
District Council where
we've had copper connections provided to
allotments which will never ever been
used at considerable expense now I must
admit under recent changes in policy at
The District Council that's got sorted
to some extent
but anyway I would Advocate that those
services are not required until such
time as somebody builds and it should be
left until that time so that's largely
what my submission is about
um
somebody saying should somebody
demonstrate this thing the services are
available but not put them on
um
oh just hiked items I know it's a survey
related matter
but it's an important one that I think
then the invercargill city council staff
are overlooking and not appreciating the
significance of it District councils
adopted New Zealand in 2016 which is New
Zealand's official datum there's
surveyors we have absolutely no choice
it's mandatory for us to work in that
datum all legal documents must be in
terms of it
and it is high time for the city to
switch over to it you you I've been
telling the city council we're
engineering staff now you will have no
choice eventually this is an opportune
time to do it
the datum you're working in terms of at
the moment hasn't been maintained for
years and years and years and and there
are simply no reliable benchmarks left
nobody's maintaining the Heights on
those benchmarks anymore most of them
have 26 to have 2016 vertical datum
Heights on them and they are maintained
taking into consideration Earth
deformation but your old datum that
you're working on at the moment not and
you say you are simply increasing the
amount of error in in the work
so
um
good on the south and district for
changing over to a constant datum um
city council you really need to have a
good look at that
um
storm water
yeah I've got to say oh look I'm I'm
it's it's one of the things I specialize
in the storm water
um so I perhaps take a bit more interest
in in it than the average guy
I'm a keen advocate of stormwater
retention I don't like the concept of
piping your stormwater off-site
discharging it into streams
um wherever possible we should be we
should be the the the code should be
encouraging the retention of stormwater
on site
um
we've got good well-established
practices that that are proving that
that can be done
um
and so like yeah I just as a general
thing there I think there needs to be
more encouragement for that in the code
um
probably at all I can say about there's
a few technical things I'll just skip
over if you've replacing your time on
them
down to five three eight no exit roads
my interpretation of the code is there's
a there's a there's a there's quite a
discouragement there for no exit roads
it's a it's a it's a so-called modern
policy
um to build these Loop roads rather than
cul-de-sex and I think it's absolutely
rubbish
I drive around these horrible new
subdivisions in Christchurch and I don't
know how the hell anybody can take pride
in those things they're absolutely
disgusting that's how I describe them I
wouldn't want to live in one of them
and I believe it's completely flawed
policy
and
people living down small cul-de-sacs
enjoy a considerable benefit from the
fact that you're living in a small
cul-de-sac with
probably no more than about 20 other
properties
most of them will know everybody in the
street
if one of them's getting out of line
with with tearing down the street in
their car too fast it's usually not long
before they get sorted out by by a few
of the neighbors you lose all that when
you put a loop right when you turn that
cul-de-sac into a loop road you get all
sorts of traffic down that road that
doesn't belong there
so I believe I believe there should be
more encouragement that well there
certainly shouldn't be discouragement in
the code against that sort of thing
um
skip over the next few things
down to 634 back to storm water again
South and District Council use a 510
your return period city council wants to
stick with the five-year sorry do I get
that right South in District 10 yeah
city council wants to stick with a
five-year return period
I I probably can understand look I might
be misinterpreting it perhaps the reason
for that is there's been an awful lot of
storm water work done
in terms of improving water mains over
you know since the 84 floods and I and
that was probably all based on a
five-year return period and so I guess
maybe it creates some problems if you
um now impose a standard of 10 years but
and then maybe look there might be some
other reasons I'm missing but personally
I think it should be 10 years anyway
um
this recent nonsense that's gone up and
on in Auckland was with the flooding and
um you know that's got a you know I mean
plenty of other people to say so I don't
repeat stuff that other people are
saying
but clearly stormwater is a big thing
now and it's going to get bigger
um
if there's a if there's a really sound
logical reason for sticking for five
years that's fine but I can assure you
all the stuff that I've done in the city
in the last few years in terms of
retention and and other things have all
been based on 10 years and they've all
been based on the on the RCP 8.5
scenario that's nearer's most
pessimistic
um
uh prediction of global warming outcomes
so I you know so I believe and I'm not
finding that using those factors is
giving me any grief in coming up with
retention devices and suitable ways of
dealing with storm water
um so I would I would be advocating at
the city council
uh have a look at that
um
yeah this one's a the next one which is
leading on from that 6389 soakage
devices this in one of our other
submitters prior to me was I'm not sure
if he was referring to this section or
not was advocating for retention of the
2mg a professional when it comes to
assessing storm water
um soakage in particular
I've had 40 years of experience in that
game I'm not a Geo I'm not a Geo
professional and um I can assure you
that I don't intend to give up that work
I've got a good track record in it
um I don't believe that I need to be a
geoprofessional in order to design a
good so-called I have the necessary
skills in order to do that and so that
is um that is a non-negotiable uh
requirement on my part I will not back
down on this one
um it wouldn't it would significantly
infect the affect the work I do the term
should be suitably qualified person
um
a couple of minor things
um about
um 1547 that's the that's the um the
Wastewater on site domestic Wastewater
standard
um there's some minor things there but
but the one that is important and it's
and it's created some issues for me
designing these systems um some of the
accounts some of the people here may or
may or may not know me but my
specialties designing domestic on-site
domestic Wastewater systems and and
on-site stormwater systems
probably accounts for about half of my
workload maybe more
um
I probably do summer in the order of
about two to three hundred of them a
year
um and had there has been instances
where this requirement to to keep the
Wastewater system entirely within the
property has caused us some grief and
it's been detrimental
it's forced me into into less desirable
forms of treatment
because I had a small site to deal with
and um
and in fact it's the wording in the
existing code which is which this is
taken from which has caused me that
grief I've been completely sensible
situations where we should have been
able to dispose of our Wastewater
off-site on an adjacent property with
suitable suitable easements registered
over the adjacent property
and we have not been able to do that and
as a result we've had to get into
considerably more complex systems to get
them on a small site
and that sort of that's not desirable
when it comes to domestic Wastewater
there's a very fundamental simple rule
when it comes to
those things that keep it simple keep it
as simple as you can
the more complex you make a system the
more chance there is that it will fail
or give somebody grief in the future
so that is something I'd like to see
gone
or qualified in such a way that at least
it's not a Prohibition and it's
certainly not prohibited under the law
they are quite common
and there's no reason why we shouldn't
know how to do them we've in fact done a
couple in recent times and clearly
there's
they got through the approval process
somehow unnoticed
in both cases there were resource
content issue for them by environment
South and so it was possible that the
the Tas in those in those cases weren't
in fact they accepted that and didn't
enforce the rule but it might seem like
a minor issue but but it hasn't been for
the couple of cases where it's where
it's uneffective
so thanks Mr chairman thanks Tom
um can I just bring you back to the
height datum yeah and your encouragement
for ICC to adopt uh nzb 16. yeah is that
a process that we would go through
through this code of practice or through
the district plan no through this
through this code yeah yeah it's in the
code yeah look the problem is
um
survey control has to move with Earth
deformation and so
um so all our control marks are moving
whether we like it or not
but unfortunately
while we continue with the existing city
council datum which has Dunedin Bluff
those marks aren't getting updated
anymore
um I must confess I can't just be
certain when they stopped on updating
them but they certainly don't update
them now a lot of those marks are the
same marks that we're using under New
Zealand vertical games in fact just
about all them probably have New Zealand
vertical datum Heights on them those
Heights are continually outdated as as
through Earth deformation but the old
the heights that are assigned to them in
the Dunedin Bluff day demand and so it's
inevitable that at some point in time we
are going to have to the city council
will have to switch and I look I can
understand their reluctance it's a pain
in the butt all our existing plans all
our GI well the gis system is no trouble
at all to change so that's just a push
of a button on the computer and the
whole lot just gets changed over
GIS guides here for the ringing what
what might not see it quite as simply as
that but
um yeah it's a pain in the butt you know
to change I know that because all you've
got thousands of planes and different
things that have
um
have been done in terms of the existing
datum
um
but it's inevitable
um that we that we do need to change
South and District
um
we did most of the data capture in our
firm for the South and district and its
existing GIS stuff we I do need to sit
down with you guys
um because I I know what the datums were
for all the various towns but that's um
and so we do have to bring their stuff
up to speed but at least now they're in
vertical and in terms of 2016
um going forward
they'll be fine
um
thanks Tom
counselors any further questions
you're
um
comments about cul-de-sacs what do you
do you see a sort of a maximum number as
being
desirable that situation look it's you
know I I never see the absolutes but you
know probably we have 20 odd houses
something 20 odd units you know you
might push that and there might be
occasions where you can push that you
never you know with all these things
it's dangerous to say it absolutes but
um
20 maybe maybe 30. um
I can't sort of think of too many
cul-de-sacs that I've done in living
memory where we would have had much more
than that in them um you know there
would have to be any there'd have to be
something a bit extreme about the case
it will certainly be a geographical
situations which just doesn't you know
that you've got a little longer
cul-de-sac because it's just no other
way of getting in there narrow piece of
narrow long piece of land that is better
dead end type so you know
um and so you might have justification
for some more Lots in some cases but you
know if you were going to have a 50 Lots
upper upper cul-de-sac you're probably
just certainly have to do some other
things to control the traffic coming and
going on it
um
you look at some
is uh Grant will a test it's uh yeah I
prepped on my old school
um but I met with Grant and city council
team there recently um I've recently got
involved in the tupura Y subdivision and
it's previously been the layout on that
was previously looking High uh heavily
at
um as a system of loop roads in fact
there wasn't a single cul-de-sac and the
whole thing
um that's just and and so I suppose I'm
probably going to be at loggerheads with
Grant this team shortly over that
because I'm about they're about to get
the pla the master plan from me in a few
days time and um there's there's loot
roads where they're needed but there's
also a lot of cul-de-sex and private
right aways which is my way of doing
things
um
you know from a developing Point
developer's point of view
um we find them very popular you know
just informal conversations that I've
had with lay people and and other
professionals at conferences and and
that and since I met with Grant and this
team
um have reinforced my view I've looked
I've driven around Christchurch and
looked at stuff which I'm repeating
myself I know but I find it disgusting
quite frankly I wouldn't want to live in
those new subdivisions though
I I would not be proud of developing a
subdivision like that
um
to me it's all about providing a place
for people to live
and traffic functionality is completely
secondary to that and I think the Grant
and this team have got that back to
front they and I hope I'm not doing them
an injustice by
by
um
by misquoting him or or whatever but I
think that they are too heavily focused
on traffic movement as opposed to
providing a place to live
um
connectivity needs to be there but going
forward into the future it needs to be
there on foot and on bicycle not on not
by cars you shouldn't be able to jump in
your film in car just to go and visit
your neighbors around the next
cul-de-sac or whatever you should go to
walk through but you also equal you know
I just hate these loot roads you know I
don't I don't think they provide a good
environment for people to living and I
tell you what economically they're not a
good idea we can we get a couple more
sections where that road was so from a
developer's point of view they're a good
thing that's not what's motivating me
here because in a lot of cases if I'm
putting two cul-de-sacs in me you know
that are head to head
are where there would have been a loop
road I'll usually put a piece of reserve
and to form to form the link between the
cul-de-sac heads where I'll make sure
there's a pedestrian Lincoln there
somewhere not too far away
so it's not really to do with trying to
get greater yield for developers but
it's still relevant
um turning up two cul-de-sacs into a
loop will involve probably another 100
meters of Road there's that as well so
the economics do come into that as well
but yeah look it's mainly about
neighborhood I would not want to live if
I had a choice I would certainly want to
live on a coal set rather than a rather
than a Loop Road
the only people going up that cul-de-sac
apart from the old person that's got
lost are people that live in that street
thanks Dom
um I think was why we've done a plan
change and that's all so we will assess
any application on its merits at the
time with an open mind Trish
thank you Don for your
fatigue have you had any feedback from
the community you mentioned you've heard
some comments but have you actually gone
out to see what people like
only only the sort of thing I was
talking about the year before where
where
um
I've talked to just lay people
yeah I suppose I I mean I could ask the
question around this room what do you
got where do you guys want to live do
you want would you seem to live in a
nice quiet private Street or would you
prefer to live on a loop Street on a
loop Street where you've got other
traffic coming through I mean for me
that's just common sense I
um I appreciate that but I think it's
also important to hear the voice of the
people now who live there you know not
not what's happened in the past
there are many elements I agree with you
but I would like to think that it's
based on people choices where you know
people's
um opinions as well extra we stick to
questions sorry
thank you
yeah um no look I've done no formal
research just just
talking to my colleagues at conferences
and talking to the odd person that you
know that might come up in a over a cup
of coffee or a beer or something like
that
um
yeah
I think
yeah thank you
thank you sorry I'm coming in welcome
to um 0.5.3 a nine around your fencing
and you put the section implies at
fencing Road boundaries would be the
norm but there are many situations when
fiducing is not required
um and this section should reflect it
more clearly can you put some more
explanation around there sorry I just
said apology I had difficulty hearing
what I'm sorry say that again I'm sorry
um 0.319 5.319
fencing
oh you fit the fencing one yeah yeah
um yeah it was just an unusual one to me
I I it might already be in the code I
think I think it may already be in the
existing code actually but
um
there's a lot of situations where
um uh frontages or subdivisions don't
get fenced
um I'd hate to I'd hate to see either or
both of the council's starting to
enforce what I think is actually already
there I'm not mistaken I think it's
already there but it's never been it's
certainly never been enforced anyway
there's an awful lot of situations where
we do subdivisions which are not fenced
and we don't want them to we often don't
want them to be fenced actually
um
okay thank you thank you enough further
questions
thanks Tom once again a great submission
and thanks for your time this afternoon
Trish
Oh Come Along
quick
I need a couple submissions
Amazon was on
telecommunications and the discretion
that Council appears on
telecommunications and electricity
um so that they don't need to be
installed if decided upon that way
through a resource consent decision and
I'll just refer to the comments that Don
made on that one in film subdivision I
would agree that really in some respects
the best time to be installing your
Telecom and your power is the time of
building conceited
um
those cables don't join well
so
um your best option is to run a line up
to the rear section and coil it up and
bury it in the ground so for a future
date and I can see that the staff
response was to take telecommunications
out of the requirement given the changes
in technology
um
but I'll just add that I do support
Donna and his view with with the
requirement to install
or income subdivisions just a quick
question on that point if you don't mind
trash
um would it be relevant to include
I understand what you're saying about
telecommunication and the demise of the
phone but but fiber optic cable
we're doing the choice
[Music]
to my property
um I'm not developing
um and so I'm I'm on a Wi-Fi broadband
connection and and a lot of people are
not choosing to pay for a landline as
well as their as their mobile
um
so I do note that the staff response in
throughout the hearing report was to
take telecommunications off the table in
terms of connection at development time
um and I support the staff response to
them thanks appreciate you coming Josh
all right so my next one was on vehicle
Crossings and I did seek some
clarification in terms of the fourth
paragraph I look at this local Crossings
I didn't actually have the Clause
reference here but in particular for
Rural vehicle Crossings
I wanted to clarify that vehicle
Crossings would be upgraded or
permanently closed if necessary
um
no let's just say that again so my
suggestion was that at the time of
subdivisional development any regularly
used vehicle Crossing that provides
access to the road shall be upgraded to
council standard
or permanently removed and the
distinction there is that the initial
paragraph of the vehicle Crossing
sections talks about all regularly used
all regularly used Crossings
I absolutely support that every property
that is issuing from a development needs
to have a primary accessed
it's constructive to stand it in the
rural context farmers can have 10
gateways down their property boundary
and the way that cruise reads currently
they would have to be upgrading every
Farm gateway to council standard and in
this if it's a sealed Crossing we are
talking in the order of ten thousand
dollars of Crossing
in the rural context and Vera over the
last couple of decades in this region
there are a shift in how Council routing
staff
interprets policy and at times it's all
the farmers gateways have to be upgraded
to Steel Crossings and at other times
it's that primary access so in my
submission I was really seeking
clarification to how this Clause is
going to be interpreted and
um
enforced really by start by Council
staff
now the staff response was a level of
flexibility for these situations as
affected the wording of this Clause will
be amended to allow Council to have
discretion in considering removal of
farm gateways so there was no comment
regarding the ceiling or bringing up to
standard of all vehicle of all gateways
that
front the road
on any property
so when you seek building consent when
you seek subdivision consent absolutely
you need to have a primary access that's
constructed extended if it's a sealed
Road that's standard is a sealed
Crossing
if you have additional gateways my
proposition is that those gateways that
are not commonly used sometimes often
only occasionally sometimes once or
twice a year that they do not need to be
brought up to that sales standard so
that's really what I'm seeking
clarification from in their Clause
that's written
the word discretion
and Council to have discretion and
considering or the removal of plant
gateways is a separish what what can be
a separate issue and if
and if severely compromised Gateway in
terms of safety then at development time
you won't find us complaining about the
requirement to close gateways so there's
two points there the closure up gateways
for safety reasons and the upgrading
when they are seldom used
um
thanks Trish councilors any questions
for Trish
no well I'm just sorry for it
disregarding your comments on gateways
and I certainly understand what you're
saying and there's a farmer I understand
it totally so the big part of the use of
those gateways is actually Farm related
whether it be stock or solidage or
whatever that might just come out over
one very short period in a year
so you see that that is a valid use for
those gateways and among all of the
other
sort of requirements that gateways have
so you're suggesting that it's only in
the case of a development of extra
um dwellings if you like that those that
rule should be implemented what
technically
Council have the local government
oh actually now this is going code of
practice technically Council can under
the bylaw anyway so someone might want
to
correct just under the bylaw under the
local government
down the road
and tell everybody that their gateways
don't come up to scratch and they can
tell them that unless they come up to
scratch they can't use them in which
case
a boating rape won't be particularly
happy and there'll be a lot of pushback
generally this only comes up when
someone is subdividing or when someone
is doing the development that is the
opportunity that farm Gateway has come
to the attention of Road and staff and
so while the project might be completely
unrelated to the use of those gateways
and often isn't I I'm not proposing that
gateways that are being
utilized more from The Proposal in front
of council I'm not proposing that those
don't require upgrades or to be made to
standard I'm saying that those go back
within there are no changes from the
building proposal land use or
subdivision proposals if those gateways
that have operated that way for a number
of years remain
not upgraded
because there is no their proposal
doesn't have any effect on the use of
the Gateway
I just have in mind what council can be
told by parents too and some of these
things happen
thank you
thank you no further questions
thanks Trish appreciate it
once again thank you to the people
who've submitted not only those who've
come along and spoken to them today but
also those who've written in what I'm
going to do now is call a 10 to 15
minute adjournment just while council's
technical staff would like to consider
some of the points that were raised in
the spoken submissions this afternoon
we should note that during that time the
live stream will continue but the sound
will be off so the sound will resume
when the meeting is reconvened so I'll
adjun the hearing thank you again
foreign
welcome back I'll reconvene uh this
hearing uh apologies for those who have
been waiting on the live stream but
we've um
given our technical staff a chance to
confer having heard the
um oral submissions today
uh just for a minuteing purpose we
should also note that Mr Nathan sharing
of fat hippo Design Group Limited
uh indicated his preference to speak at
the hearing however because of a
conflict and a schedule it wouldn't be
possible for him to attend well we're
coordinating two councils
and it is a shame that he was unable to
attend today but we weren't going to
reschedule it for one submitter we do
however have their written submission
which of course does form part of
um process
so having been through and conferred
probably the best way forward is for us
to go through
um
the code of practice and blocks and if
staff want to make
um make known any changes that
that they feel are acceptable and as we
get to each of those blocks councilors
if you have any questions after having
heard the submitters that you want to
ask that'll be the time to do them
so the simple ones start first with
Clause 1.4
actually if we've got copies of that can
we send it around to the
parents panel introduction
so Clause 1.4 the Clause should be
updated to clarify the extent of
jurisdictions between the code and the
building act and to include flexibility
for some infrastructure to be
constructed under engineering approval
instead of building consent any
suggested changes to that
nope so that remains as it is
the next block of Court Clauses are 2.1
2.2
2.3 and 2.4
foreign
too fast
that's the plus of paper sometimes it's
easier to quickly flick through
and I must admit I've got a paper cheat
sheet
so from a staff perspective any comment
on
1.23405
I know we're getting a photo topic for
you
but the uh
Clauses are in the code of practice yes
none
okay next one's a larger block
which is uh 1.6 clause 3.2.5.4
down to
1.15 which is clause 3.2.20.3
foreign
just had a question around the
um provision of services like the phone
and the electrical
um and there's a submitter that talked
about oh there's a couple actually I
talked about her need
is it needed for info rather than new
subdivisions and I thought they made
some some reasonably good comments there
about the why you would leave the
services to be connected to the time of
building
um
I thought that was worth having a think
about I certainly agree with the not
having to have the telephone line and
stuff like that would that would make a
few of our ratepayers really happy
um I've heard about that one a bit but
yeah I was just thinking for unful
particularly
sure which clause was there
that was around I think it's
3.2.41 and the change of
Telecommunications
and it's just the discussion around the
power cable as well for info I'm not
sure if it's totally there or somewhere
else but
yeah so we're after a little bit of
comment from me were you thank you
looking at me so well yeah with uh yeah
cool sure no I'm I can um sort of
um primarily help out with the
infrastructural considerations that were
made um by the various teams as we broke
off and talked about these things look
um we we really didn't make any
distinction between infill versus
Greenfield style
um developments uh in our discussions
the prevailing thought from the the the
teams that broke away was
um as sites are being created they
should be fully serviced in in the scope
of
um access three Waters and utilities all
falls within that realm so we thought
that
um Power uh is an essential service
um so there absolutely needs to be
hooked up uh telecommunications is a is
a bit of a different Beast these days
just have a look at what's happening
with uh the likes of Stalin for instance
so yeah it's fully illegitimate that um
the not too distant future
um people may not be needing that as a
physical connection
yeah I guess some people might suggest
that they'll be similar with power you
can pretty much
of great room beat yourself succession
as well
yeah well I suppose that's getting back
to the whole we're so in an urban
situation yeah and this is a joint so we
need to consider that
um you know if someone was was doing a
rule it could be considerably cheaper
for them to go off-grid than to run
cabling to the subdivision at times yep
no I think it's a legitimate
consideration but um yeah again
um the The Joint will of of the times
that went away and worked on this was
that uh you know we considered uh Power
to be a fairly essential service
um that should be installed at the time
of subdivision so if I can use an RMA
comparison when you've got something
that doesn't
necessarily conform
if there's a design option that
mitigates in in this case say
off-grid power
is that an acceptable consideration
under a code of practice
uh absolutely we can consider it and the
code of practice isn't meant to be the
be-all and end all necessarily so we
um acknowledge that there will be
acceptable and alternative Solutions
um and if it's appropriate to use that
we'll certainly consider it
because while one person in a particular
property might think it's wonderful to
be off-grid and all the rest of it the
person that owns that property next
might be the last thing they want so I
think something as basic as electricity
should have a provision
and I've even
heard of people that have gone off grid
and then actually
time after a while
but then they can pay a connection fee
it was just about getting the
um getting the infrastructure in there
but it's a it's a buyer beware thing if
you're if you're the person who is
buying a property that is Off the Grid
you are aware of that when you're making
the purchase and you can make the
decision to to purchase the property and
go through the infrastructural costs to
get it connected so it's not like it's
something that's not blatantly obvious
but it needs to be available to a
boundary anyway
or it would be available to the roadway
anyhow at minimum well maybe some
exceptions with power on Long
-way roads
good point with the telecommunication
the reason that south of District
dogmatically stuck to it for so long was
in the past we're quite large areas of
Southland that didn't have phone
coverage and there were some and it was
the thought about emergency calling
really that was the main motorbike
not quite there yet it's not till next
year that we're all off satellites but
that's true yeah
anyway
peace son how are we going to ensure the
standards around what is a suitably
qualified person
who wants to handle that
I guess it's up to it's it can be
similar to qualifying somebody as an
expert witness it's up to them to to
prove their qualifications
I would tend to agree with that as well
that's how it works on practice
that years of experience
override or was equal to
a piece of paper
so it depends on what the years of
experience isn't
so if it's let's use the example of Mr
Moyer if it's in stormwater design and
he's done a couple hundred every year
and he's still in business
that tends to indicate he's reasonably
competent at what he does so he would
therefore be a suitably qualified person
are they registered
in any way before that varies from
um trade to trade
so some don't necessarily require
registration so
okay on those Clauses in here other
questions or changes
yeah I'm on 1.6 down to 1.15
you know I wrote down a note yesterday
on 3.19 about fencing and I cannot find
it today for the life of me so I don't
know whether I dreamed it or what I
think it might have been a question
about the height of fences and certain
situations
Heights of fences would normally be
controlled by the district plan not
necessarily the code of practice Yeah
certainly in an urban environment here
with our district plan
the smarter related to where there was a
walkway foreign
visibility
for Public Safety point of view
don't follow what I said because I
thought I got it wrong
all right so this might be in relation
you you're thinking is right it might be
in relation to uh crime prevention
through environmental design we call it
accepted might have heard of that Clause
before we're certainly
um uh you know adjacent to walkways in
particular we do try and limit the
height of fencing
um just so there's there's passive
surveillance and turn out of
um uh small spaces like that
uh 3.2.5 which was the height datum that
was raised from an ICC perspective is
there a response to the
comments made by Mr Moyer
um yep I think there are actually a few
submissions on the use of correct datum
and and the latest datum standards that
we use throughout the industry there's
an acknowledgment in our response to the
submission that those are generally
correct and we'll be making
the required amendment to that Clause so
reflects best practice thanks thank you
any other questions or comments on that
block
if not the next blocks of beauty that's
1.16 down to 1.35 so take your time as
you have a look through but from the
staff perspective any points that you're
wishing to raise first of all
[Applause]
um no no suggested changes to our
recommendations but happy obviously to
answer any questions we'll have
okay so I'll give you a moment if you've
got any questions please feel free to
sing out
the cause the first one the Clause
5.3.3.4 to do with that 0.5 percent
versus point four percent that's
just fine the way it is with the like
yeah that's that's right yeah those are
sort of Fairly industry standard
um values to use
um there was a submission suggesting uh
I think was it from absolute land
suggestions suggesting that even flatter
um great but we're pretty comfortable
with what's in there in terms of the
recommended in minimum grades where site
dictates
on the right at the end of it the what
is going on here and I think the
5.4.12.2 it's about Timber edging and
there's a there's a meta made a comment
that it only gets smashed up by mowers
anyway Etc so I just wondered what your
thought on that was
um yeah I haven't to be fair I haven't
had a lot of experience with uh Timber
reaching uh particularly in relation to
um asphalt put parts here in
invercargill I have in Dunedin a lot of
my Traders uh formulating from Dunedin
and in Dunedin
um uh yeah it's it's a worthwhile
um uh each to put in as a structure each
structural each to a footpath and helps
it uh helps the footpath stay together
um basically
so the submission our response there was
that yeah essentially as I've said that
if a um asphalt foot path um is is hand
laid then it's appropriate to retain
foreign
as an appropriate surface for private
rural private ways however the first
five meters of the vehicle Works he's
within the site must be had supers to
reduce loose material migration from the
side so if that's on a full Gribble Road
it's a full Gribble driveway and
someone's doing a fold on that place the
expectation is that they're going to
have five meters of tarsial or
hard surface put on there yes yeah
that's correct that's from the edge of
the the sealed road to five meters
inside the property boundary it's only
on a sofa it's on so there's nothing to
think just a Gribble road coming into a
driveway it's only on a sealed Road it's
only on a sealed Road that's correct
yeah it doesn't apply to it sealed Road
it's a gravel gravel no offense
are the questions on anything in there
if not
next block goes from 1.36 which is
clause 6.3.4
through to 1.46 which is Clause 6.5
there was a
suggestion
um from staff to amend clause 6.2.8 in
relation to climate change following
um the submissions we heard today
um I'll obviously let my colleague speak
to their technical details but um what
the um agreement in principle was is to
change that Clause to remove and
reference to temperature increase of 1.5
degrees
to amend the reference to the design
Horizon to 2050 to 2080 which apparently
aligns with one of the other standards
that was used and finally to amend
um the wording around the design event
and to read the design event is to be
suitable to the site I.E the peak
critical event
you've got always being emailed
thank you for that
Council has any questions from you the
acknowledgment of the issue around
climate change was the question that I
had so that's maybe almost
okay thank you so we then move the next
block goes from 1.47 which is Clause
7.3.10.3 looks like an old telephone
exchange uh through to clause 1.52 which
is uh 7.7.3
staff suggestions
so that I'm not sure where the resist
the
section that talked about manholes
there seemed to be some
concern about
being
exactly
the great ones for extra safety point of
view and also from a installation point
of view
do you remember that comment this
morning yeah I did recall the comment
I'm trying to find a submission point
um it was by wsp yep yeah all right yeah
um referring to the wrong manholes
getting ordered
expert
[Music]
we did discuss that
um
review of the submissions
and we didn't
really feel like
we fully understood what they were
asking
um but our opinion was that with the
amount of mass concrete that we expect
to be around
the main hole that we've not had any
problems that we're aware of
um and
shortening the life of the manhole's
expected life of the manhole so
whilst there possibly is better practice
that we could be following
um
we'd need to look into that and
I think that's probably something we're
doing the within the next year rather
than
just we haven't seen any problems so
just from a process we've got we're
bringing in the code of practice and
just a reminder it only sits in place
for a year which gives us a chance to
see how everything beats in so if during
that year we do find that there is an
issue that was raised in the wsp
submission that there's a chance for
that to be addressed
I think Mr support did Ray so that they
were being stolen properly
yeah that was raised
and so for me it's more around you know
ensuring that we've got the standards
right that they are being stored
consistently
yeah well change standards have changed
significantly since the
Christchurch earthquakes and we are
probably lagging behind in that because
we just haven't had the resources to
keep up with that so is that a
compliance issue or a Contracting issue
but one of the things that I push well
it's just that we haven't adopted
necessarily the latest standards but so
one of the things that I did push to be
included in the new code of practice was
around the work that's been done around
seismic
um resilience
um some of those issues that were raised
around storm water connections for
example yeah yeah
um I might be able to add to that a
little bit as well um because I do
recall that submission point now a bit
more more detail and it was around the
sort of seismic performance of those
um uh manholes particularly given the
the Christchurch example and you're
right I had a chat with our three Waters
team about that specific point as well
um and as Brian has mentioned
um typically we put a lot of concrete
around those manholes as well so the
connections that go into them have a lot
more support so it quite comfortable
with how our industry performs
um at the moment in the installation of
those manholes
um uh if there's a better way of doing
it of course we've got this 12 month
period where I think that we'll be
looking into some of those submission
points in a bit more detail but we
didn't think it was appropriate to
change what we're doing at the moment
um particularly because we we
um have eyes on a lot you know those
installations ourselves anyway so we're
we're doing that quality assurance side
of things as and when these are being
installed
um a I do our own contracts and B under
Land Development projects as well
um so yeah I think that there's no
change that's recommended
um
um particularly at this point in time
but but it's a submission that we have
noted and it will be monitored over the
next 12. yeah yeah a great agreed yeah
thanks
just a question around that um 12-month
process and what's in place to kind of
ensure that the things that are picked
up here and talked about is kind of
going to progress to a review in a year
so um there will be a process put in
place to capture all events coming up
um
that will be obviously a parallel
process so both invercargill city
council and at Southern District Council
um essentially the review for all
intents and purposes will start very
shortly so um I think the hearing panel
can be assured there isn't a lot of time
for things to get dropped and forgotten
um conversations will commence with tell
marama quite quite shortly and several
of the points that might not have
resulted in action changes from today
are things that are going to be
considered and monitored
okay so that's a process once once we
get through this anything else between
one four seven and one five two
if not I'm going to move from uh 1.53
which is clause 8.3.9
through to 1.63 clause 8.5.3.4
okay
any staff comments about that no changes
[Applause]
counselors any questions
largely 4matic actually
so the 8.3
to do with those water main laterals and
the earthquake resilience perhaps their
sleep Builder
I think that's quite a important one to
get in front of as it were
which submission point is that
um what I wrote down if I've got it
right is 8.3.10.1
foreign
connections yeah how is water
connections
yep that's page 176
sure thank you
um
again it was the feeling from our team
that there's no change required to this
the detail that's in the code of
subdivision
um is a standard detail that performs
well for our Network we didn't see a
need to change that
and even with talk about af8 and all the
rest of it do you not think that there's
some value in thinking about resilience
in the future oh yeah it's probably part
of a much wider sort of look at
resilience so that was kind of kept it
off just previously Paul and that it's
something that we're going to look at
how we can Implement over the next 12
months it was part of that yep
although the the relevant Clause fell in
8.10 I think you're quite right yeah I
think it did yeah
foreign
minor amendments any
changes there
if not
1.678 and 9.
again
uh and there was a um an amendment
needed
um from
Staffordshire
um
Clause
10.4.1 needs to be amended
um suggested the easiest way to do that
was to change the words at the
termination of to the word for basically
just to make sure the the Clause was was
written wrong basically
um there was never any intention to um
require developers to to do maintenance
after five years so we just wanted to
change that and to correct that thank
you
that's one minor addition
now the questions on that
and that brings us to 1.70 through to
1.80
I'm done
right with those
sorry Paul I must have missed it but um
the issue that Chris Fortner was
bringing after regarding Farm gateways
Etc
um
what is there some thoughts about that
yeah so um our recommendation on that
was
um
actually I'll just double check just to
make sure uh that I am
foreign
so yeah the the recommendation on there
was to I mean the wording to allow for
some flexibility then the consideration
of farm accesses
um the concern there was that farm
accesses by and large
um uh put in without reference to
council without any sort of formal
approval necessarily because they use
every once in a while mostly
at the time of subdivision uh the
feeling was that we wanted to retain
discretion just in case any of those
have been put in in an unsafe location
or if there was material for example
tracking onto the road that was causing
an unsafe Road surface so we just wanted
some flexibility there to be able to
have a look at them I think that we're
we're reasonably happy that they don't
that every Farm access doesn't need to
be brought up to a to a
driveway residential driveway standard
that would be the case for the the main
axis but
that was the the thinking of the team
that we just wanted to retain some
discretion there so that it remains
discretionary the um I think new ones
are required experiments yeah yeah the
historic ones there's a lot of historic
ones but also uh you go past um some
sites and you know a new gate might have
been put in an existing fenceway so I
think it still is happening
um but again
um if they're being used once in a blue
moon and they're not causing a safety
issue then it's probably something that
that we're not going to
um uh you know pull out a bylaw or an
LGA process to get rid of them
um but at the time of subdivision we
want to particularly we want to retain
that discretion to to have a look at
those Farm accesses just to make sure
they're safe
we understand that you were saying that
at the time of subdivision there may be
still some Farm accesses that are don't
have to be brought up to that level
and I think that's just a pragmatic way
of managing the new group
sorry I missed that too what do we think
about Don Moyer's idea about
um allowing disposal of Wastewater on a
neighboring property
do we have a response to this submission
certainly not something we can do
desirable I would have thought that too
yeah I mean um it opens a large can of
worms
not good being able to have Wastewater
disposal on small Lots
perhaps suggest this
support shouldn't be that small
but as with everything we're open to
um
suggestions from the developers and
where they can provide appropriate
justification so there is the
opportunity for discretion if there's an
appropriate design solution presented
yeah
it always has been
something where
because um and just cover everything
yeah
is after
a profusion that we're
um
suggesting throughout these documents
and
we're open to reasonable Justified
Solutions
that and I think just to just to close
that point off that um you know uh don
was talking about the complexity of the
system in terms of its physical
Arrangements but then the proposal is
potentially quite a complex thing in
terms of its legal arrangements as well
um in who's to know how that system
would be maintained in perpetuity into
the future I just I have some real
reservations around that
depend on those things with the next
person coming along buying the property
here discover something that they
perhaps went
aware of
okay so we are at recommendation five
and essentially it is as we have in the
agenda but with the addition of 6.2.8
around the climate change figures and
10.4.1 which is a change of words for
formatics
rather than at termination of two four
those are the two changes
so the recommendation with those changes
is the remover
Finance seconded Darren
put that then all in favor against
carried recommendation sex as a
recommendation to the invercargill city
council to revoke the code of practice
for Land Development and sub subdivision
infrastructure bylaw 2016.
and adopt the code of practice for
subdivision land use and development
with the recommended changes that we've
just noted under five Trish
and uh
pania seconded it because she brushed
her hair at the right time
do you ever go to Todd's
we ended up with a lot of furniture that
way
okay move to Second it'll put that all
in favor against carried recommendation
seven is uh to Southland District
Council to revoke the subdivision land
use and development bylaw 2012. and
adopt the code of practice for
subdivision land use and development
with the recommended changes that we
have just noted under five
yeah
councilors Duffy and Robin claw thank
you
put that all in favor against carried
uh eight notes at the invercargill
district plan hearings uh postponed
until such time as the proposed code of
practice has been finalized
Barney and Trish thank you
put that all in favor
against
carried and notes the period for
submissions on the Southland District
plan will be extended by two weeks and
hearings will be scheduled to follow
this period if required
thank you
put that all in favor against carried
and finally notes that the first review
of the new code of practice which is
what we were just talking about will
take place in a year to enable feedback
from developers along with technical
input from talmarama on how Tau Maori is
incorporated and I think that's one of
the things that we've dealt with here
thanks pania seconded
Darren thank you put that all in favor
against carried
councilor thank you very much
um for your attendance and consideration
thank you very much more so to the staff
who've worked collaboratively in the
background to to come to a new way of
doing things
um saying 20 something years he says
mumbling
um that's the first time we've gone down
that particular Rabbit Hole this far and
it's really encouraging so thank you
very much for that
they're being no further business I will
close the meeting thank you